this is a production of cornell  university  good morning i'm up in the organic  vineyard at cornell orchards  and uh we're looking at a vine this is  called arendelle  it's from the cornell breeding program  it used to be called uh new york 95  030101  and uh it's basically a no spray red  hybrid so people are really excited  about its disease resistance  so what i wanted to show you on this uh  basically is that it is just starting to  go blueberries in here  silver raisin of course is when the  fruit changes uh color and you start to  see some ripening acids start to  decrease sugars go up and the big thing  is that we have some berry softening so  here you can see the green berries are  really hard when i go to squeeze them  but the red berries are actually softer  so this is the onset of ripening and we  will harvest this fruit probably in late  september  this has been a production of cornell  university on the web at cornell.edu